[Music]
Bonz Beethoven Fest is a major and
highly prestigious classical music
festival every September over 50
concerts feature in the main program
alone naturally that includes music by
Ludwig van Beethoven in 2017 for
instance Spanish pianist Javier parry
Ana's played the fourth piano concerto
of course planing in the city like born
and playing Beethoven is something very
special and that should be because it
means a lot for the for the musicians to
play in a city that where I was born
Beethoven
[Music]
20-17 was xi Beethoven fest where
Deutsche Welle
organized a public viewing on bonds
marktplatz square
this is one de ba it's wonderful to have
this and Vaughn I brought him along he
comes from Iran and I just wanted to
show him the Beethoven festival here it
was really a good atmosphere I like it
this Vincent mission gun showing yellow
camping I think it's nice that you can
bring along your camping chairs and
enjoy the whole thing in a completely
different atmosphere as a Beethoven fest
media partner Deutsche Welle
invited some prominent guests every year
the Beethoven fests director Nick Ivana
spotlights a new slogan in 2017 it was
about unfulfilled desire everyone knows
Beethoven had a hard time when it came
to love he never found happiness with a
family of his own
he had his long-distance affairs with
his aristocratic piano students but he
was always unhappy so the theme is fine
graphical but it also allows us to hold
a festival under the general slogan of
love leave it the perfect slogan to
bring people closer to the music of
Beethoven at this year's public viewing
of the Beethoven fest
[Applause]
you